في الحقيقه مع بدايه هذه الساعه بتوقيت
وتاريخ كيف تكون قد دخلت همم اوكرانيا
وكيل في العام الجديد العام 2023 انا اقف
هنا جيلان في ساحه القديسه صوفيه وهي
الساحه الرئيسيه للاحتفالات باعياد
الميلاد وبراس السنه الميلاديه ستحرق
قليلا لتشاهدي معي الصوره هذه هي هذه هي
كنيسه القديسه الصوفيه والتي كانت دائما
في كل عام تكون مزينه
وايضا الاضواء وهنا حيث اقف في هذه الساحه
طبعا همم كما تشاهدين خلفي هذه الشجره
الميلاد هي تقف هنا بائسه ومظلمه همم غير
مضاءه طبعا كانت تعمل بمولد للكهرباء
والان كما تشاهدين في وقت الاحتفال نفسه
هذه شجره الميلاد مظلمه غير مضيئه هذه
الساحه كما تشاهدين غاليه تماما الا من
رجال الشرطه ونحن المواطنين الان في
بيوتهم يحتفلون طبعا الغد كيف في ليس فقط
في العاصمه وانما في جميع المدن
الاوكرانيه كل مظاهر الاحتفال وشددت على
حضره التجوال وايضا هنالك عقوبات لمن يقوم
بخرق همم حظر التجوال والشرطه منتشره في
جميع انحاء المدينه منعا لاي همم يعني
عمليات خرق لي حظر التجوال هذه الساحه
التي نقف فيها جيلان في العاده كانت تكون
هنالك حلقات التزلج وايضا الخيام الخيام
الحلوه والمشروبات الساخنه كل ذلك يغيب في
هذا العام كانت ايضا تنصب المسارح هنا وفي
الاتجاه المقابل وايضا في ميدان النصر وفي
شارع الخير الشاطئ وتقام الحفلات العامه
وتحتفل الاكيد وتغني وترقص ولكن كما
تشاهدين هذا العام طبعا امين انه كان
هنالك هجوم اليوم في النهار على العاصمه
اكيد وعدد من المدن الاكرانيه وهمم لاحقه
ايضا هجوم اخير في المساء في الولايات
الجنوبيه والولايات الشرقيه جيلاني